I wish I could spend every minute with you.
Mommy has to work so hard.
I mean, you could reframe that all of your
great success at such a young age has
positioned you to be able to spend time with
your baby. Yeah.
What about play dates and hanging out with
kids? Because at five months, moms are all
getting together and dads.
Like all
my cousins, my sister, everyone's doing music
classes and all of these mommy and me things
together, and I don't have time to do any of
those things.
So. Could you bring them to you, like, have a
class here? Yeah, I've been
wanting to do that.
But then I also get nervous with him being
around so many people because he's so little
that he'll get sick.
This seems to me it could be a little bit of
a trauma response that if you bond with him
more and take him out and about, something
bad's going to happen.
Yeah. Can you hear it in what you're saying?
Yeah. So when it comes to trauma and
anxiety, we always want our decisions to be
made on data, not feelings.
What's good for development with children is
that thousands and thousands of interactions
that they have with their mothers, back and
forth in the first two years of life, the
mother actually regulates the child's
heartbeat, respiration, holding the baby.
You're still regulating all of his systems.
Yeah. And gazing eyes back and forth.
Yeah, that's really good for their
development. Um, talking to him.
Oh, are you hot?
Like he's hot in his pants.
Is he hot?
I think so. Does he a
little onesie on?
Yeah.
They're like.
Oh.
Are you hot?
The baby nanny.
She always loves being so hot.
Like the heater is always on.
I always say, isn't he hot?
And she said, no, they like it.
Okay. So this is where you should trust
yourself in terms of what what you think is
good for the baby.
You are the mother.
Yeah.
She's not.
I know, but she's like done this millions of
times.
You've given up authority to the baby nanny.
I'm sorry, but that's wrong.
It is.
Because you're the expert, not her.
It doesn't matter how many babies she's
raised. That's your baby.
You're the expert on your child.
I think the question is, do you want the
nanny to be the primary attachment figure,
or do you want to be the primary attachment?
I think that you should ask yourself that.
I just feel like I'm not responsible.
Okay.
What you're telling me makes no sense.
If you were so irresponsible, you wouldn't
have a multi-billion dollar empire.
It makes no sense.
So how much do you want to change this?
Because I can help you work on it.
But I don't want to force you.
I think about just, like, figuring out that,
like, work life balance.
Like, I love what I do, and I feel so
grateful just to be in this position, but I
definitely don't want to miss all the
moments with him.
Mhm.